and even mergency sisters the Wind River  Indian Reservation  I'm June banner FBI welcome to Wyoming  by yourself you see that's Cory Lambert  he's right he found the body  like this on the side I knew that girl  she's a fighter  because big office areas to cover an  area the size of Rhode Island  maybe you can't really know what's Drac  say what is it you do again monitors so  why don't you come hunt one for me then  why would a teenager will be out here  like she running from the other clues  but you missed them all sides  shouldn't we wait for backup this isn't  Landa backup James this is a land of  you're on your own  oh my god you won't get the answers  you're looking for matter what you find  why your daughter run from home I don't  know why just tell me you can happily  n'ever this place it takes most little  new lockers in the city  okay won't on them out here  [Music]  you